the other day I was thinking about just
how much i love church I mean I really
love church this thought came to me the
midst of a particularly hectic time full
of the noise of busy days mixed with the
songs of lament that this life in this
world all too often hold you know the
type of noise I'm talking about right
the dominant static of our lives the
need to do should have don's less than
worries anxieties and you know the songs
of lament the losses and sources of
grief the confusion and suffering in our
own lives in that of the world another
life taken to gun violence in new hovel
up the street this past week the state
sanctioned death of a possibly innocent
man unimaginable drought and hunger and
Somalia joblessness and hunger and New
Haven the poet Vikram Seth rates the
world is too opaque distressing and
profound and so it sometimes feels it
was with these feelings of lament and
the static and clutter and noise that I
thought the other day about how much I
love church how lucky I feel to have the
chance weekly or sometimes more than
weekly to come together as a faithful
people of God to lay our burdens down to
lift up our souls to receive God's Word
in prayer silence and song I don't know
about you but as a child growing up I
came to know about God first in the
songs the familiar hymns of Christmas
the doxology of praise the this little
light of minds which somehow seemed not
only to reveal God but to allow me to
purchase
hey in the mystery of God somehow and so
it still remains in the midst of the
world and my life's confusion and pain I
love the church in its music to listen
to the hair-raising anthems of the choir
to feel the rhythm of the pipes blasting
in the organ or to experience the
cadence of voices saying singing the
songs in to sing our song God song
together song has been from the church's
earliest days part of our corporate life
with one another hymns offerings of
praise have been part of that life
plenty of the younger wrote to the
Emperor 107 siiii about those Christians
who were accustomed to come together on
a regular day before dawn to sing
alternate alternately to Christ as to a
god and today in a portion of Paul's
letter to the Philippians we hear what
scholars called the christ him fragments
probably of an early sang our song of
praise quoted by Paul in his letter to
the Philippians who two came together in
worship to sing to God their Lord Jesus
Christ this is a special letter Paul is
famously writing from jail an
imprisonment that tradition tells us
would lead to his death during the
persecution of Christians indeed writing
his last letter to his friends good
friends who had once called upon Paul to
help them out in Philip I a former Roman
colony with some level of status but who
we learn from other letters of Falls
that they too are facing persecution and
so an anticipation of death as a last
word to his friends his family and
Philip I full of their own songs of
lament also facing a to opaque too
distressing world Paul writes a last
word for his friends well
and he includes the text of a well-known
praise him and so this is a special him
it's as if we were on our debt beds and
we knew our friends and family are in
trouble and had but one letter to write
and we chose to include the lyrics from
a favorite song from one song which song
would you choose it would have to be a
special song and Paul chose this one of
the Equality of God of Christ with God
Jesus is humbling and human form in
Christ exaltation and raising up we
recognize in the Christ and maybe words
that have taken on a life of their own
in our own tradition Christian tradition
traditions composers musicians have over
the centuries incorporated portions of
the Christ him into their own songs some
of which we may love at the name of
Jesus every knee should bend in every
tongue confess that Jesus Christ is Lord
yet some of us might have a hard time
with this hymns lyrics or its profession
some of us might be a little uneasy
about this term Lord in a world where we
honor and cherish our democratic ideals
and resist the autocratic this language
might feel foreign to us or even
dangerous some of us might wish to
confess and repent for the ways in which
Christians have and continue to distort
the Christ him to justify some false
sense of our own righteousness or worse
to justify practices of violence or
hatred coercion such as colonization
slavery the Holocaust you only have to
go online to see that these very same
words are being used to justify hate
against Muslims and Jews out of our
fears and our hatred we cast images of
ourselves and build them into
all idols God is pretty clear on the
subject of false idols as people seeking
to walk in faith we know that we're
meant to tear them down but where does
that leave our Christ him needing to be
sung I think because at the heart of
this him at the heart of Paul's
quotation in his letter to his friends
in Philip I rooted in christ lordship
there is a different type of lordship
one that challenges and transforms
worldly for worldly forms even as it
offers hope in a world to come one that
offers a different vision for power
altogether a different vision for being
with one another a way to get through
the hard times a song to be sung not
just on Sunday but every day through
this life and the life to come now when
I knew I was about to preach on the
Christ him and the song took out a
physics textbook of a friends I'm not a
scientist and not a music theorists so
forgive me if I oversimplify or get this
wrong but the basic gist I think in
music that there are moving objects
vibrating stuff that gets transformed
into energy that are waves which then
are perceived in in music there's a
foundational vibration that then there
are intervals upon which we build and
create the marvelous music become so
used to and glad to hear in church
something has to set it off in motion
some vibrating stuff and here in our
Christ song we hear about that
instigator the Word made flesh come to
earth the Lord Jesus Christ who is our
foundational frequency in this day and
age it's hard to imagine how to truly
outrageous nature of our songs claim in
the day of Paul and the Philippians how
those vibrations would have been so out
of sync with the vibrations of the day
the time of Roman imperialism in
invincibility Christians were ridiculed
for worshipping a god who had become
human a nobody a Nazarene who hung
around with prostitutes and tax
collectors the losers of society and he
would die for them this type of ridicule
might not be that far off from some of
what those of us in a cadet academia in
this modern world get from skeptics I
mean how can you really believe this
stuff the question was the same and Paul
in the Philippians time how can you
really believe that Jesus is Lord in
this type of AD a sink pneus this type
of outrageousness and Paul's time was
dangerous so I did a little more
investigating in the physics of music
and I guess there's different different
physics to differ instruments pipes or
flutes wind instruments have vibrating
air inside of them and to have those
frequencies make the sound that we come
to hear you disrupt those vibrants if
you disrupt those frequencies those
vibrations some vibrations need
disrupting to make music and it was a
mighty disruption that Christ's word
brought to Paul's time to profess that
Christ is Lord was to go against the
cult of the emperor who was proclaimed
Lord in those
it was to go against the prevailing
philosophies of life and death to like
on the cover of our bulletin today to
have Magi Weisman the Kings go to visit
a baby in the most ignoble of conditions
and to call him Lord what a racket that
would have made but to us our song of
that God who crazy in love would become
incarnate live a life of ministry among
prostitutes tax collectors sinners and a
ragtag band of disciples teaching us how
to love one another dying and being
raised so that we might have life the
heart of this song of the lordship of
Jesus Christ is God's love song for us
the music to our ears that rings not in
noise or racket but harmony in Seoul
lifting joy that we experience here that
we come here every Sunday to reset our
frequencies to get in tune with our
foundational frequency Christ's love
song come to earth
now I love church but that's not enough
so the physics of sound tells us that in
order for it to be heard has to be
received and us here pitching ourselves
as part of the music making that happens
in so many ways in worship needs to
carry out into the world Paul talks a
lot about unity of mind and spirit the
setting this tuning that needs to be
carried out is a corporate undertaking
and Paul tells us work out your plural
salvation because God is working in you
that word work and aggie oh I believe in
Greek is where we get the word energy
from God is our energy and in sound we
know that the energy is what makes its
loudness it's it's amplifier so we as
the instruments of God pitching
ourselves to the tune of God's love song
Christ Jesus who is Lord are amplified
by God working in us in how we use our
bodies to make music out in this world
this is not some lofty up in the sky
thing this is a practical real thing
that we are we are instruments than to
use our bodies Paul tell talks to the
Philippians about what that means and in
other places he refers to how they've
lived that life giving donations to
Jerusalem after they faced famine
working against divisions towards
healing
I love church and at the heart of our
life together is our foundational
frequency Christ and our Christ him but
it must be song let us make our noise
out in the world into music